Genau, also darauf wollte ich eigentlich auch hinaus. Das ist eben der Grund zur Unterschied. Bei Streamer habe ich wirklich einen getrennten Account. Das heißt, den kann ich, wenn ich möchte, mit meiner Telefonnummer verbinden. Und ich kann auch mein Telefonbuch sinken, aber ich muss das nicht. Und das ist der große Vorteil. Ich muss nicht preisgeben, wen ich alles kenne. Und nicht jeder, der meine... Ich muss auch meine Handynummer nicht preisgeben. Das heißt, Leute, die meine Handynummer haben, können mich zwar weiterhin anrufen und mir SMS schreiben oder so, aber können mich nicht unbedingt über Streamer zu erreichen. Ich kann wirklich ganz genau auswählen, mit wem ich eigentlich kommunizieren möchte. Und dann habe ich halt sozusagen verschiedene Sicherheitsstufen. Das heißt, erst mal ist ich habe nur die ID von dem bekommen, irgendwie, den fahre ich auch auf einem anderen Weg. Das ist sozusagen unsicher. Sicherer ist, wenn es noch eine Telefonnummer zum Abgleich gibt. Aber der sicherste Weg ist und das ist vollkommen unabhängig von der Telefonnummer, ist, dass zum Beispiel Danimo und ich wirklich uns Angesicht zu Angesicht zueinander stehen und einen sogenannten QR-Code, die kennt, glaube ich, mittlerweile ja doch jeder, anzeigen und der andere den einfach scannt. Und dann auch in die andere Richtung. Damit wissen wir genau, dieser Account, den ich dann auch angezeigt bekomme, gehört zu der Person, die mir gegenüber steht. Und wenn ich mit dem schreibe, rede ich wirklich mit dieser Person.
Und das ist kein Muss. Das ist genau. Ich kann mit ihr auch so kommunizieren, aber dann bin ich mir halt nicht wirklich sicher, ob das wirklich Carina ist. Okay, der Nachteil bei 3MA ist, kann man sagen, der ist nicht open source. Das heißt, da kann nicht jeder einfach reingucken in den Quellcode. Wie ist es bei dir, Matthias? Was hast du auf dem Handy?
Na ja, ich habe auf jeden Fall auch 3MA natürlich. Aber ich muss auch sagen, ich habe auch WhatsApp, weil na ja, es gibt halt außerhalb des Nerdkreises auch noch sozusagen die erweiterten Freunde und so weiter.
Du bist ein Kandidat für eine 50er-Paket-Lizenzen verschenken.
Und sagen wir es mal so, also prinzipiell ist WhatsApp natürlich auch Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt. Von daher ist es jetzt auch nicht so ein...
Aber da fallen ja die ganzen Metadaten an.
Richtig, die ganzen Metadaten liegen eben genau wieder bei WhatsApp. Und da Facebook ja WhatsApp quasi wieder eingemeindet hat, liegen sie auch wieder bei Facebook. Und das ist natürlich ein großes Problem an dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Und man muss auch davon ausgehen, dass Facebook langfristig auf jeden Fall die Sachen zusammenlegen will. Im Moment haben sie da ein paar rechtliche Probleme. Es gab ja sozusagen neuer schon die Bemühung, die Telefonnummer sozusagen weiterzugeben.
Was da erstmal zurückgezogen wurde.
Sokrates, nur ganz kurz, wie ist es bei dir?
Ja, ich hab auch nur Streamer und halt ganz viel Jabber.
Alles klar, haben wir das auch geklärt. Wir machen eine ganz kurze Pause und sind dann hier wieder zurück im Chaosradio im Blue Moon.
Radio hat einen Namen.
So, herzlich willkommen zurück im Chaosradio Blue Moon Another Night Another Run war das mit Breakbeat Heartbeat. Wir reden heute hier über viele verschiedene Themen und haben zum Beispiel gerade mit und da möchte ich noch einmal begrüßen Danimo, Carina, Matthias und Sokrates. Hallo. Hallo.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Wir haben über Weihnachtsgeschenke geredet und da möchte ich doch gleich die geschickte Überleitung machen. Apropos Weihnachtsgeschenke shoppen, Sokrates, du wolltest uns über Online-Rabatte aufreißen. Du sollst jetzt sagen, amerikanische Weihnachtstraditionen wie Halloween kommen ja sozusagen immer mehr aufs Festland nach Europa. Und da gibt es auch den Black Friday und Cyber Monday oder irgendwie so Blue Monday oder irgendwas, also quasi so riesige Online-Rabatzangebotsdinge. Und die sind jetzt nicht toll oder wie oder was? Was genau?
Es gibt da sehr, sehr viele Unterschiede. Das ist sehr Datenbanklastig. Also die Preise unterscheiden sich bei manchen Shops da auf dem Grund, was du für ein Gerät hast, mit dem du diese Preise abrufst oder nach der Suchmaschine, die du benutzt. Und vor allen Dingen auch, welche Tageszeit du benutzt. Und das ist halt sehr, sehr schwierig. Also da sollte man ganz genau hingucken und nicht nur nach dem ersten Mal auf irgendeiner Preissuchmaschine.
Warte, nein. Das heißt, ich kann nicht wie in der Vergangenheit immer sagen, ich brauche unbedingt ein neues technisches Gerät XY. Ich gucke einfach bei der Preissuchmaschine, zack.
Nee, das wäre nicht so gut. Und vor allen Dingen solltest du nicht unbedingt mit einem, leider Apple-Gerät, ah, sorry.
Wieso, was passiert da?
Weil dann sind die Preise automatisch teurer.
Na ja gut, ich meine, das hatten wir eigentlich schon bei Hotelsuchportalen und so weiter im letzten Jahr. Oder was, vor zwei Jahren bereits schon. Also ich meine, das ist ja jetzt nichts Neues.
Aber wie umgehe ich das denn?
Ähm, setzt dir einfach ein uraltes Windows auf. Aber nicht, nur suchen, nicht shoppen bitte.
Aber da muss ja wiederum, ich wollte gerade sagen, da muss ich wiederum sagen, okay, ich komme also mit einem Applegerät auf einer Preissuchmaschine und denke so, ha ha, Applegerät, der hat viel Geld, dem können wir es abziehen. Aber wenn ich mit einem alten Windows Computer komme, denke ich so, ha ha ha, der merkt gar nichts, dem können wir viel abziehen.
Dann nimmst du halt so ein Mittel, aber bitte kein Windows 10. Kein Windows 10, die Dinger sollte man sowieso nicht nutzen. Warum? Weil die, also das ist die Hölle.
Ach, was?
Also Datenschutztechnik, die diese Metadatengeschichte, die die da haben, oh Gott.
Spezifiziere?
Pass auf, ja, das ist das Problem, das haben wir noch nicht ganz raus. Aber Microsoft sagt offiziell, dass sie Metadaten von deinem PC analysieren, und zwar live von allen.
Was heißt Metadaten?
Ja, Metadaten, was sind Metadaten eines PCs? Im Endeffekt gehört zu Metadaten alles, was du tust. Also das Öffnen einer Datei, das Öffnen einer Webseite, alles. Also alles, was du tust, gehört zu Metadaten. Die Dateien selbst wahrscheinlich nicht, aber das, was du tust. Also du öffnest jetzt den Pornonummer X3, was weiß ich, oder irgendwas.
Aber wie das sammelt, Microsoft?
Die Metadaten, ja. Mit Windows 10.
Werden übertragen an...
Ja, genau.
Und was machen die denn damit?
Auswerten. Also die wollen damit wahrscheinlich auswerten, ob du irgendwelche Funktionen nutzt, die die einbauen und ob du mitbekommst, hey, das neue Icon-Nummer, was weiß ich, nutzt du das überhaupt oder nutzt das überhaupt irgendjemand und deshalb wollen die das wahrscheinlich haben.
Also diese Sammlung von Metadaten ist hier eigentlich in allen Bereichen immer damit begründet, dass sie sozusagen sagen, ja, wir wollen das Nutzerverhalten analysieren, damit wir unsere Produkte besser machen können und optimieren können. Aber natürlich gibt es auch noch ganz viele andere tolle Wege, wie man das Ganze nutzen kann, zum Beispiel um eine personalisierte Werbung anzubinden. Oder es gibt da auch so gewisse Behörden, von denen wir schon den ein oder andere gehört hatten, die natürlich auch richtig gerne dann mal ein paar Informationen dazu haben, bei Leuten, wo es sich interessiert. Das ist halt immer die Gefahr. Das ist halt immer die Gefahr, weswegen man so was von Anfang an vermeiden will. Denn wenn Daten da sind, werden sie genutzt. Das sehen wir immer und immer wieder, auch egal wie sehr uns vorher versprochen wird, dass es nicht passieren wird.
Verspricht Microsoft gerade noch, nur wir haben diese Daten?
Nein, nein, nicht mal das, sondern Firefly, diese Firewall Firma hat gerade diese Daten bekommen.
Wer ist das?
So ein blöder Firewall-Hersteller, Schlangenöl und so.
Das ist ein Firewall-Hersteller, was ist Schlangenöl?
Dinge, die du nicht kaufen willst, die eigentlich schlecht sind.
Das, was die fahrenden Händler früher verkauft haben in der Behauptung, es heilt dich von allen Krankheiten. Also sowas wie Homöopathie. Genau. Richtig. Warum ist eine Firewall-Homöopathie?
Eine Firewall selbst ist keine Homöopathie, aber das, was diese Vionscanner und diesen ganzen Kram, das ist Homöopathie, weil es nicht funktionieren kann.
Inwiefern?
Weil die Benutzung eines PCs so dynamisch ist und so individuell, dass du keine wirklich guten Heuristiken erkennen kannst.
Was ist eine Heuristik?
So ein Antivirus-Programm erkennt erst mal Dinge, die es kennt oder von denen es weiß, wie es sie erkennen kann.
Aber das hilft mir doch schon.
Ja, im Moment, das hilft aber nur gegen bekannte Sachen.
Aber das ist schon mal gut.
Aber das Problem ist, die ganzen Bierenhersteller, äh Hersteller, also die ganzen Autoren von Schadsoftware letzten Endes sind ja auch nicht blöd. Die entwickeln ihre Software letzten Endes auch weiter. Und die finden auch neue Wege und auch neue Wege, sich im System zu tarnen. Und eine Heuristik ist letzten Endes etwas, was sozusagen einen bekannten Weg formalisiert, um eine solche Schadsoftware im System zu finden.
Warte mal, also sagen Bieren-Scanner machen zwei Sachen. Nämlich das eine ist sozusagen Viren erkennen, von denen man ganz genau weiß, wie sie aussehen.
Oder wie man sie erkennen kann.
Also sogar ein verdächtiges Verhalten?
Ungefähr, ja genau, das Verhalten ist verdächtig.
Und die Aussage ist sozusagen, Viren-Scanner können dieses verdächtige Verhalten nicht wirklich sicherstellen.
Wenn ein völlig neuartiges Verfahren zum Beispiel auf den Markt kommt und eine völlig neue Art und Weise, wie mit diesen Dateien oder mit Netzwerkverbindungen umgegangen wird, dann kennt eben das Antivirus-Programm dieses Verfahren nicht und hat entsprechend kein Heuristik dafür, um das zu erkennen.
Hab ich verstanden, möchte einen Vergleich bemühen. Sicherheitsscanner am Flughafen schlagen nur an, wenn die Pistole, die ich in meinem Gürtel habe, aus Metall ist. Haben wir aus vielen Agentenfilmen gesehen, aus Plastepistolen oder aus Knete sozusagen gehen da durch. Trotzdem finde ich das eine gute Idee, dass die Metallpistolen nicht durchkommen. Viren-Scanner kann ja sozusagen, also okay, kann ich alle Viren erkennen, aber zumindest die, die bekannt sind, ist doch auch schon mal gut oder nicht?
Theoretisch, aber das Problem ist ein anderes. Und zwar, viele Viren-Scanner haben Angriffsmethoden genutzt, um zu sehen, was du gerade tust.
Was?
Ganz viele von denen verwenden zum Beispiel einen Man-in-the-Middle-Angriff. Also, klinken sich zwischen deinem Browser in das Netzwerk hinein und schauen zu, was du für Trafik machst. Das bedeutet aber, sie können all das, auch wenn du HTTPS im Browser siehst und sagst, das ist jetzt eine super sichere Verbindung, dann haben sie die trotzdem schon aufgebrochen und können mitlesen, um halt so eine Sachen zu sehen. Und das sind halt echt böse Dinge, die verhindern, weil sie dann wieder ein Stück...
Das heißt sozusagen, Virenscanner machen das, was Viren machen, damit sie Sicherheit garantieren? Oder Angreifer.
Die machen das, was Angreifer machen, benutzen diese Tools, um halt Dinge zu erkennen, die total schwierig sind.
Und das Schlimme ist dann in ihrem Bemühen, dass ich auch wirklich, wo ich auch wirklich glaube, dass sie das richtig machen wollen. Aber die Materie, sich da reinzuklinken und quasi alles das, was jetzt so ein Browser-Hersteller und so ein Betriebssystemhersteller mühsam mit mit richtig viel Qualitätssicherung irgendwie da reingebaut hat, sich da dazwischen zu klemmen, sorgt halt immer wieder dafür, dass Virenscanner oder generell Sicherheitssoftware Lücken aufreißt, die vorher eigentlich in Abwesenheit dieser Sicherheitssoftware gar nicht dagewesen wären. Also warte, ich meine Virenscanner installiere ich auf meinem System, der macht dann Dinge, die normalerweise Angreifer machen, unten macht neue Löcher auf. Ist das ein Verdacht, den ihr habt? Nein, es gibt mehrfach immer wieder Paper von Security Researchern, also Sicherheitsleuten, die das beruflich machen, die dann leider immer wieder in dieselbe Richtung stoßen. Das ist wieder so ein Punkt, wo ich jetzt einfach sozusagen rausgehen möchte und ich mache jetzt Musik an und dann wiedersehen.
Ja, das ist eben die gute Launesendung.
Aber deswegen ist es eben die viel bessere Empfehlung, einfach sozusagen versuchen, sich intelligent im Netz zu verhalten. Das heißt einfach, nicht auf random Sachen zu klicken. Weil die Sachen, die bekannt sind, die alt sind, die, die die Viren-Scanner sozusagen erkennen, das sind die Sachen, die werden rumgeschickt. Wie gesagt, das ist alt, das hat oft auch die gleichen Angriffe immer wieder. Also ja, es schützt davor, dass ich irgendwie einen gefährlichen Anhang aufmache. So, der bessere Tipp ist, mach keine Anhänge auf, die du irgendwie nicht weißt, von wem es ist oder die komisch aussehen. Du brauchst nicht die 500 lustige Powerpoint-Präsentation, die dir irgendein Kumpel, mit dem du irgendwann mal zu tun hattest, geschickt hast. Na ja. Mach die zu. Aber. Lass die zu.
Also ich nicht, du nicht, du halt auch nicht. Aber es ist ja so, es kommt ja in der Zeit, die Zeit, wo die Eingeborenen nach Hause um ihren Altvorderen und so weiter und so fort. Und dann sagen die ja, ja, kannst du nicht dann vielleicht noch so mal einen aktuellen Virenscanner irgendwie drauf machen. Das heißt, ich nehme, ich schlussfolge aus dem, was ihr sagt. Nee, lieber nicht, sondern lieber sich eine Stunde hinsetzen und ein sicheres Verhalten im Internet beibringen. Und wenn du ihnen unbedingt was installieren willst, installiere ihnen einen gescheiten Adblocker. Einfach aus dem Grund, nicht weil wir, ich glaube, das haben wir hier schon mal thematisiert, in einer anderen Sendung. Es geht nicht darum, irgendwen zu schädigen, was als Seiteneffekt halt durchaus passieren kann. Aber, also sprich die Leute, die mit der Werbung dann das Geld verdienen. Aber es ist einfach so, dass es ein ungelöstes Problem ist und auch auf absehbare Zeit sein wird, diese Werbung so zu gestalten, dass dort nicht finstere Leute ihre Mailware mit dieser Werbung ausspielen können. Weil man muss sich das so vorstellen, Werbung im Internet ist nichts anderes als ein Last-Minute-Bieter-Wettstreit um den höchsten Preis auf einem Werbeplatz. Und wenn ich jetzt als Viren-Autor gerne dich targeten möchte, entweder weil du ein bestimmtes Betriebssystem hast oder ein bestimmtes Surf-Verhalten hast oder so, dann kann ich das tun und kann dir, weil ich zum Beispiel weiß, dass du den Browser XY verwendest mit der und der Sicherheitslücke und kann dich mit individuell für solche Werbung bespielen.
Na, das ist ja auch genau der Punkt von so einem Werbenetzwerk. Die Werbenetzwerke sind darauf optimiert, eben genau getargetete Werbung auszuspielen. Das heißt, sie haben genau demografische Regeln und weitere Kriterien, mit denen du genau exakt dein Zielpublikum für deine Werbung aussuchen kannst.
Inklusive wer ist das CEO im Firmenetzwerk XY? So gut kommt man daran. Okay, ich hätte also gesagt, wir nehmen heute viele Themen dran. Hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass wir so schnell springen. Ich gehe also nochmal zurück über das, was wir gerade gesprochen haben. Nicht wie ein Scanner installieren, sondern lieber Adblocker.
Und ein Under-Script, ganz wichtig.
Und nochmal sozusagen gutes Verhalten üben.
Genau, wobei man da auch echt aufpassen muss. Was ist denn jetzt schon wie? Es ist überraschend, was Leute so schaffen. Ich habe zum Beispiel, ich sage jetzt nicht wem, aber meinem Bekanntenpreis beigebracht bei E-Mails, wenn das Mails sind, wo er nicht so richtig weiß, da auf jeden Fall nicht drauf zu klicken. Also auch Fishing-Mails, also Mails mit Links, die sagen hier, das ist dein Paypal-Account oder so, da ist was passiert, klick doch bitte hier mal und guck mal, wir glauben, da ist Betrug, das ist so eine ganz beliebte Masche, damit die Leute dann da draufklicken auf die falsche Seite, kommen ihre Eingaben machen und dann sozusagen, man den Login-Daten abgreifen kann. Das habe ich ihm beigebracht und gesagt, okay, das darfst du auf keinen Fall klicken hier auf so Sachen, wenn du dir unsicher bist, leite mir das weiter. Und dann war ich gerade verreist, komme wieder und sage, ja, du hast gesagt, ich darf da nicht draufklicken, aber unten stand eine Telefonnummer, da habe ich angerufen. Da war ein sehr verwirrter Mann drum, der gar nicht wusste, worum es geht. Also das finde ich auch eine sehr schöne. Also da habe ich dann auch gelernt. Also manchmal kann man gar nicht weit genug denken, was man alles erklären muss. Ich habe dann eben dieses Regel-Set erweitert, um auch bitte keine Nummern anzurufen, die in E-Mails stehen.
Ignoriere alles, was in der Mail steht.
Ja, genau, also ruf da nicht an. Also schick das, wenn du dir unsicher bist, schick das mir, dann sage ich es dir. Und bei der Mail war das Schönste, dass ich meine Rückfrage war, sag mal, hast du eigentlich Paypoint? Dann muss ich es mir gar nicht angucken, dass es Spam. Also da muss man manchmal wirklich noch ein bisschen zurückgehen und überlegen, was muss ich jetzt genau erklären. Manchmal kann es wirklich rudimentär sein, so wenn du irgendeinen Dienst nicht nutzt, dann ignorier die Mails, die es dir schickt. Das ist dann nicht für dich. Und wenn irgendwas ist, geh auf die Webseite, wenn es ein Dienst ist und guck sie da an. Und damit kann man schon viel, viel mehr abschrecken, als eben so ein Virenscanner das eigentlich kann, indem man den Leuten einfach intelligente Surferhalten erklärt. Und dann können die Leute eben auch deutlich beruhigter auch ihr Handy oder so in die Hand nehmen, weil da ist ja das gleiche Spiel.
Und vor allen Dingen auch so Rechnungen kommen immer per Post, wenn es dringend ist. Niemals per Mail.
Wenn die E-Mail versucht, Druck aufzubauen im Sinne von in drei Tagen sperren wir das Konto, wenn du jetzt nicht hier klickst oder wir haben irgendetwas geändert, dann ist es mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit ein Versuch, dich auf einem, naja, sagen wir mal, etwas abseitige Seite zu weiterzuladen.
Das geht nicht für Mails von der Mutter, die fragt, ob du zu Weihnachten kommst. Ganz wichtig, die nicht ignorieren. Das ist noch gefährlicher.
Na, die hört sich doch auf WhatsApp.
Um sozusagen, also falls sich jemand einen Fünchchen Rest Hoffnung hat, dass vielleicht doch alles gut ist und denkt, ich setze mich jetzt an meinen Rechner, setze einfach meinen Kopfhörer auf und höre ein bisschen Musik, dann kann ja nichts passieren. Außer, dass dir jemand gerade mal... Ja, danke, bitte. Ja, ich wollte... Erzähl bitte, danke schön. Naja, tut mir leid. Du magst zwar gerade was hören, das ist dann auch in Ordnung. Aber wenn du den Kopfhörer vielleicht mal gerade beiseite legst, dann ist vielleicht nicht mehr in Ordnung. Matthias kann das, glaube ich, besser erklären.
Du legst einfach den Kopfhörer beiseite und dann stellst du fest, hm, okay, ich habe gerade eben eine voll Raumüberwachung freigegeben, weil Kopfhörer, was, okay, ich gehe einfach mal einen Schritt zurück. Was ist eigentlich so ein Kopfhörer? Ein Kopfhörer ist so ein Gerät, das, naja, macht Töne. Und diese Töne macht es, indem halt da elektrische Impulse reingeleitet werden, die einem Membran anregen. So weit, so gut. Also wir schieben quasi Energie rein, die Membran wird angeregt und es werden Schallwellen abgestrahlt, die dann auf dein Ohr treffen.
Strom macht Ton.
Richtig.
Gut.
Was allerdings auch geht, ist, wenn man selber etwas sagt oder irgendwie generell Geräusche produziert im Raum, dann strahlen diese Schallquellen auch eben Energie ab und diese Energie trifft wiederum auf diese Membran und diese Membran wird dann von außen angeregt und fängt an zu schwingen. Und das Schöne ist, es entsteht dabei Strom.
Okay, Ton macht Strom, Strom macht Ton. Aber die Mikrofone, in die wir hier reinsprechen, die sie dir extra dafür gemacht haben, du sagst, Kopfhörer, mit Kopfhörern geht das auch.
Genau.
Das ist mir noch verständlich, dass ich einen Kopfhörer auch als Mikrofone benutzen kann. Aber der Kopfhörer in meinem Rechner steckt ja in einer Kopfhörerbuchse. Und die ist ja nur dafür da, dass die Soundkarte, also das digitale Gerät in dem Rechner, Sound nach draußen gibt.
Ja, das war auch eigentlich ursprünglich mal eine ganz gute Idee. Allerdings kam dann irgendwann der User. Und der User hatte sich dann gedacht, ja irgendwie stecke ich jetzt einfach mal dieses Mikrofon in, naja, das ist irgendwie so eine Buchse, da passt das schon irgendwo mit rein. Daraufhin hat sich zum Beispiel ein Hersteller namens Realtek gedacht. Ja Mensch, ist ja irgendwie doof, wenn die ganze Zeit User bei uns an der Hotline anrufen und sagen, ja irgendwie mein Mikrofon geht nicht. Geben wir doch einfach dem User eine Softwaremöglichkeit, einfach jeden beliebigen Anschluss an meinem Rechner für einen Mikrofoneingang zu nehmen. Das ist ein ziemlich altes Feature eigentlich in diesem Chipsatz und auch schon ziemlich, naja, auch relativ gut unterstützt von der Hardware. Also wenn man je nach Rechner, wenn man da eben ein Mikrofon ansteckt, dann kommt da so ein kleines Pop-Up und sagt, ja, also wir haben hier gerade ein kleines Mikrofon angeschlossen, wollen sie nicht eben halt das Ganze auch irgendwie jetzt als Eingang verwenden. Genau, und jetzt wurde ein kleines Proof of Concept geschrieben, also so eine kleine Demonstrationsmalware.
Also das heißt, das gibt es noch nicht als echten Virus in der Wildbahn, sondern es ist ein praktischer Beweis.
Genau, es wurde jetzt einfach mal demonstriert. Ja, das Ganze kann man natürlich auch ohne Userinteraktion machen und einfach mal so den Kopfhörerausgang zu einem Mikrofoneingang machen. Und wie gesagt, Strom macht Ton, Ton macht auch Strom. Und diesen Strom, den kann man dann ein bisschen verstärken. Und dann hat man im Prinzip aus seinen Kopfhörern ein Mikrofon gemacht und kann dann in den Raum reinhorchen.
Nicht so qualitativ, aber man kann hören.
Es geht ja. Also im Prinzip, it's not a bug, it's a feature.
Warte mal, du hast doch gefragt, wo die Studiotür ist. Danke, danke, danke. Also Dagen, das ist jetzt ein praktischer Beweis, dass die Theorie funktioniert. Man muss aber schon auch sagen, das ist auch schön, das zu erzählen, weil Dagen halt so eine krasse Nummer ist. Aber der praktische Nutzen außerhalb von Geheimdienstenaren ist jetzt aber nicht so groß.
Naja, also ich sage mal so, je nach Angriff, oder wie man so schön sagt, Threat Model, gibt es ja durchaus Leute, die klemmen dann in ihrem Rechner das Mikrofon ab und so weiter und haben dann ihren Rechner soweit dann...
Nein, nein, das meine ich nicht. Also wenn jetzt jemand eine Möglichkeit herausfindet, wie er in sozusagen beliebigen Rechnern vorgaukeln kann, das wäre das Login zu einer Bank. Dann verschickt er einfach massenhaft Mails und dann infiziert er damit vielleicht irgendwie 5% und macht damit Gewinn.
Naja, so sagen, was man so hier muss, im Prinzip der Rechner schon infiziert sein.
Nee, worauf ich hinaus will, ist sozusagen das Angriffsszenario. Hier ist er sozusagen so, okay, dann kann ich jemanden dem Rechner abhören. Das heißt, für einen gezielten Angriff ist das vielleicht sinnvoll als Geheimagent oder weißt ja geier was, oder wenn ich halt wirklich jemand abhören will. Aber das ist nicht so ein Ding, wo man jetzt damit rechnen muss, dass jetzt irgendwie tausend Millionen Angriffe damit gefahren werden. Naja, das nicht. Also du hast recht, aber wir haben ja, was diese, was jetzt z.B. Spionage per Webcam angeht, durchaus immer wieder Fälle gesehen, wo und da ist der Angriff natürlich, meistens jemand im näheren Umfeld und hat meistens auch Zugriff auf den Rechner. Das ist schon alles richtig. Nur, dass ich die Kamera abklebe, da habe ich jetzt letztens ein paar Veranstaltungen gehabt mit Schülern, die haben mir damals gesagt, ja klar, machen wir sogar schon teilweise. Da war ich total überrascht. Wer würde jetzt auf die Idee kommen, seine Kopfhörer abzuziehen, wenn man mal kurz weggeht und nicht gerade wird?
Okay, da sollte man dran denken. Aber was mir gerade einfällt, wo wir vorhin bei Geschenken waren, man sollte sich die Anleitung von seinem Smart TV genau durchlesen, weil bei manchen Anleitungen im Smart TV steht ganz doll drinnen, man soll vor dem Gerät, egal ob es angeschaltet oder ausgeschaltet ist, keine privaten Gespräche führen. Das ist kein Witz.
Genau, das ist nämlich das Problem. Viele denken ja, okay, ich hör da was mit, da muss jetzt einer sitzen und zuhören und entscheiden so, da ist jetzt was, damit können wir irgendwie was anfangen. Aber dem ist ja nicht so. Also wir haben ja schon gelernt, dass eben diese Überwachung automatisiert ist. Und genau, dass das sogar schon im User-Umfeld, also im ganz normalen Anwendungsumfeld im Haushalt angekommen ist, zeigen eben die Smart TVs, die irgendwie darauf reagieren. Und auch die Telefonen, wenn man irgendwie sagt, okay, Google oder... Genau, oder all diese verschiedenen, die es jetzt gibt, die dann auf irgendwelche Stichwörter hören, die hören halt permanent zu und schicken deine Informationen an einen Server, der sozusagen analysiert, was sagst du da? Ist das gerade was, worauf wir hören sollen? Und dann darauf reagiert.
Richtig, sie müssen ja auch zuhören, weil sonst könnten sie ja nicht auf Hallo Alexa, okay Google oder Hallo Siri antworten.
Genau, aber das bedeutet halt, weil es diese Technologie ja offensichtlich schon gibt und sogar im Hausgebrauch überall, dass es eben die Möglichkeit gibt, Text mittlerweile ganz gut, also auch gesprochenes Wort ganz gut, automatisch zu analysieren, zu gucken, welcher Text wurde da gesprochen. Und darauf kann man dann ja wieder, also ob es jetzt Text ist oder sozusagen Sprache, der eben in Text umgeformt wurde, darauf kann man dann wieder wunderschönes Data-Mining machen und gucken, was kommt denn alles so drin vor. Das heißt, es muss gar nicht einer zuhören, sondern man kann sozusagen interessante Sachen dann highlighten. Das kann sich dann sogar noch mal einer anhören, wenn man will und da dann Informationen rauskriegen. Und das ist eben fürs Social-Engineering ganz spannend, weil man einfach interessante Informationen kriegt. Aber auch Social-Engineering. Das nennt sich, das ist sozusagen, wenn man versucht, durch, also hier ist es...
Vertrauensbildende Maßnahmen.
Genau, so Informationen zu bekommen, damit man dann auf einer sozialen Ebene die Leute austricksen kann. Also, indem ich sozusagen irgendwie Erfahrungen bringe. Also, es kann auch sein, dass man eben im Müll sucht.
Also, das sagen wir einfach mal im Marketing.
Ich belausche jemanden und sage dann, hey, du hast du nicht neulich von Dingens geredet? Wir kennen uns doch sehr gut.
Oder ich suche Müll irgendwie und sage, ey, hier, ich ruf dich an, ich bin deine Bank übrigens hier, Sie haben doch dann und an Geburtstag und so, ich muss das validieren. Ja, das habe ich auch als Daten oder so. Wir brauchen das und das wegen dieser Sicherheitslücke. Also wenn man so Sachen anruft und dann eben persönlich agiert, sozusagen das nennt sich Social Engineering, um eben sozusagen die sozialen Möglichkeiten auszunutzen, um eben irgendwo Zugriff zu bekommen oder so, was man eigentlich nicht haben sollte.
Das Vertrauen, das erst mal fehlt, aufgebaut. Und die Grund, die Basis dafür kann auch sein, dass man mich mittels meiner Kopfhörer belauscht. Sehr schön.
Wer möglich.
Ich ziehe jetzt meine Holzhütte und werde dort Figuren schnitzen und gleich ein gutes Buch lesen. Aber bevor wir darüber genauer reden, machen wir noch das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichtenwetter und Verkehr.
Und sechs weiteren Top-Nachwuchs-Acts. Dezember in den Blackbox-Hallen Pankow. Und mit ein bisschen Fritz und Glück könnt ihr dabei sein. Denn Karten gibt's nirgendwo zu kaufen, sondern nur zu gewinnen.
Klickt einfach fritz.de slash n-n-a.
Und vielleicht seht ihr da eure nächste neue Lieblingsband. Und natürlich übertragen wir den auch live und im Radio.
Um kurze halb 12. Mit Timo Maschewski.
Der Pilotenstreik bei der Lufthansa ist ein weiteres Mal verlängert worden. Die Gewerkschaft Cockpit hat am Abend mitgeteilt, dass auch übermorgen noch gestreikt werden soll, dann sollen vor allem Langstreckenflüge betroffen sein. Morgen, am dritten Streiktag, trifft es dagegen überwiegend Kurz- und Mittelstrecken. Rund 830 Flüge wurden für morgen gestrichen, für gestrandete Passagiere sind am Frankfurter Flughafen Feldbetten aufgestellt worden. Lufthansa und Cockpit streiten sich um mehr Geld für die Piloten. Die deutsche Polizei hat einen 20-jährigen syrischen Flüchtling festgenommen, der sich Zutaten für den Bau von Bomben besorgt haben soll. Der Mann habe sich eine Zeit lang in Deutschland aufgehalten, heißt es von der Staatsanwaltschaft in Stuttgart. Als er letzte Woche mit dem Versuch gescheitert sei, nach Dänemark auszureisen, habe man ihn in Ulm festgenommen. Nach ersten Hinweisen könnte der Mann mit der Terrorgruppe IS sympathisiert haben, er sitzt in Untersuchungshaft. Vor der Küste von El Salvador im Pazifik hat es ein starkes Erdbeben gegeben. Das Beben hatte nach Angaben der US-Erdbebenwarte eine Stärke von 7, 0. Eine Tsunami-Warnung für El Salvador und Nicaragua wurde mittlerweile wieder aufgehoben. Über Opfer oder Schäden ist bisher nichts bekannt. Nicaragua befindet sich im Moment ohnehin in Alarmbereitschaft, weil Hurricane Otto dort heute auf Land getroffen war. Entlang der Küste wurden Tausende Einwohner in Sicherheit gebracht, die Schulen wurden geschlossen. Fußball-Bundesligist Mainz 05 ist in der Gruppenphase der Europa League gescheitert. Im Rückspiel beim französischen Rekordmeister Sainte Etienne schaffte Mainz nur ein 0 zu 0. Schalke setzte sich gegen Nizza mit 2 zu 0 durch. Schalke stand aber auch schon vorher als Gruppensieger fest. Die aktuellen Temperaturen Berlin-Hellersdorf hat 0 Grad und Charlottenburg 2 Grad. In Prenzlau sind es minus 1 Grad, Wittenberge hat 0 Grad, Potsdam meldet plus 1 Grad und Forst hat noch plus 4 Grad. Viel kälter wird es nicht mehr, die Tiefstädte liegen nachts zwischen minus 2 und plus 2 Grad. Der Himmel ist meistens klar, es kann sich stellenweise aber Nebel bilden. Auch den Tag über bleibt es oft trübe, mehr als 4 Grad sind dann nicht drin. Und auch am Samstag wenig Sonne, am Sonntag dann aber wieder schöner. Vorsicht auf der A24 Hamburg, Berlin. Zwischen Herzsprung und Neuropin laufen immer noch Leute auf der Autobahn. Auf der A10, dem südlichen Berliner Ring, Richtung Dreieck Werder wird gebaut. Zwischen Ludwigsfelde Ost und Ludwigsfelde West ist die linke Spur gesperrt, da kann es ab und zu mal länger dauern. Und ab morgen werden die Bauarbeiten bei der U-Bahn-Linie 7 ausgeweitet. Bis Sonntagbetriebsschluss müsst ihr dann zwischen Britz Süd und Rudu auf Ersatzbusse umsteigen. Dort, wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn ihr gute Tipps in Sachen Mode, Filme, neue Platten, Bücher oder Games wollt, dann klickt doch mal fritz.de slash Tipps.
Heute mit Markus Richter im Chaosradio im Blue Moon, wo wir viele verschiedene Themen bearbeiten. Das heißt vor allen Dingen erklären, wie schlimm die Welt eigentlich wirklich ist. Und dazu herzlich willkommen zurück nochmal Sokrates, Matthias, Carina und Danimo. Und wir haben festgestellt, wir brauchen eine extra Gesellschaft, die die Regierung verklagt, weil die komische Gesetze beschließt. Wir brauchen nach Gerichtsentscheidungen wird aber trotzdem alles ignoriert. Und eigentlich ist auch alles kaputt und wir werden überwacht. Und es ist fürchterlich und Schlangenöl. Und hört euch die letzten anderthalb Stunden nochmal ein Podcast an, wenn ihr wirklich verzweifeln wollt.
Und jetzt weißt du, warum bei uns mal es diesen Spruch gibt, vielleicht einfach was mit Holz machen.
Oder Orchideen. Ich wollte gerade sagen, so im Jahresende, also bevor ich in die Berge ziehe, in die Holzhütte, nicht mit Internet und vielleicht auch nicht mal mit Strom, gibt es noch den Chaos Communication Congress. Zwischen den Jahren, die es so schon heißt, also ab 27. 26. ist das Tag Null.
Wir reisen nur alle schon am 26. spätestens an. Das heißt nicht, dass es dann losgeht.
Also es gibt den Chaos Communication Congress. Und das ist nochmal was? Das ist das Jahrestreffen des CCC und alle der Leute, die dem Hacken und der Kultur zugetan sind und sich gerne informieren möchten, austauschen möchten und eine gute Zeit haben. Und was passiert da? Und wo ist das? Das ist in Hamburg im Kongresszentrum. Und da sind vor allen Dingen Vorträge. Da sind sogenannte Assemblies, wo sich Leute verschiedener Fachrichtungen um einen Tisch hocken und Besuchern und Interessierten zeigen, was sie so machen, was sie so können und wie man mitmachen kann. Also Hacker unter sich und sonst niemand? Nein, eben nicht. Also den Leuten, die vorbeikommen. Das heißt, jedem, der sich für das Thema interessiert.
Wie viele Leute sind denn da?
15.000?
Ja, nicht ganz so rund.
13.000?
Auf jeden Fall über 9.000.
Okay, ähm, die, ähm, so rund, es geht aber jetzt schon. Wir haben das gesehen, große Gehämmer, es gibt keine Tickets mehr. Was, wie, warum? Ich meine, fünfstellige Anzahl Leute, keine Tickets mehr. Wie passt das zusammen?
Wir haben mehr Bedarf von Leuten, die kommen wollen, als Platz für die Leute. Es ist sehr schade, aber es ist leider so.
Genau, es ist einfach immer beliebter geworden. Die Leute sehen Artikel in Zeitschriften, auf Online-Seiten, die sehen Videos und die sehen einfach, es blinkt, die Leute haben Spaß. Es ist auch einfach, wenn man sich das anguckt, faszinierend.
Ja, es ist eben das große Nerd-Weihnachtsfest letztlich.
Und, äh, die wollen alle kommen. Und es sind einfach mehr, als in dieses Haus reinpasst. Also, wir waren ja früher in Berlin, da waren es, glaube ich, so 3.000, 3.500 Leute. Oder auch mal dann irgendwie ein 5.000. Dann ist es schon echt aus allen Nähten geplatzt. Und dann sind wir halt nach Hamburg, da war es größer. Und dann ist es innerhalb von jedem Jahr so unheimlich gewachsen, dass wir irgendwie nach zwei oder drei Jahren schon wieder ausverkauft waren. Das war der Hammer. Weil einfach die Leute immer mehr über den CCC mitbekommen, durch auch so schöne Sachen wie hier dieses Chaosradio. Und einfach sagen, ich will da mal vorbeigehen, ich will mir das angucken, ich will sehen, wer das ist, was die machen. Und ich will vor allem in Kontakt mit denen kommen. Und ja, dann haben wir halt das Problem, dass mich leider nicht jeder, der kommen möchte, ein Ticket abkriegt. Und so ganz stimmt das auch noch nicht, dass es keine Tickets mehr gibt. Denn wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe, gibt es morgen noch mal eine Verkaufsrunde.
Früh ist um zehn.
Um Gottes willen.
Also quasi mitten in der Nacht.
Für so was muss man dann immer Opfer bringen und früh aufstehen.
Ich habe sogar schon von Leuten gehört, die sich da für einen Tag frei nehmen.
Dann versucht man halt noch ein Ticket zu bekommen. Und ich kann da einen Daumen drücken.
Sagen viele Leute, die nicht wissen, worum es geht. Das heißt, man geht dann früh um zehn irgendwo hin oder man auf eine Webseite.
Und dann klickt man und hofft, dass man unter den ersten ist. Also mittlerweile gibt es da sozusagen dann eine Schlange, in die man sich virtuell anstellt. Da kriegt man eine Nummer.
Unter tickets.events.ccc.de im Übrigen.
Genau. Und dann kriegt man halt eine Nummer und dann rückt man nach und nach nach. Also die Leute kaufen auch verschieden viele Tickets und irgendwann sind dann alle weg und bis zu irgendeinem Punkt der Schlange ist es halt gegangen, genauso wie wenn man sich irgendwo anstellt und Tickets kaufen möchte. Da weiß man ja auch nicht, wie viele jetzt jeder vor einem kauft, ob eins oder drei oder irgendwas.
Was kann man denn noch daran teilnehmen, wenn man kein Ticket mehr bekommt?
Das gibt es irgendwie aufs Mit überall, everywhere.
Es gibt unterschiedliche Hacker Spaces, also so Räume, Örtlichkeiten, wo viel gebastelt wird, die das ganze Livestreamen und die partizipieren und die haben VPNs zu uns und so weiter und so weiter.
Zum einen kann man virtueller Teil des Kongressnetzes werden, das haben unsere Netzwerkejungs das sogenannte NOC, Network Operation Center, immer geschaffen und das ist immer ganz vorteilhaft, wenn man Sachen probieren will, die sonst eigentlich nur vor Ort gehen, netzmäßig. Die andere und die andere viel wichtigere Sache ist, zusammen streamen gucken, wenn man in so ein Huxbase geht. Da gibt es derer verschiedene in Deutschland. Normalerweise gibt es auf events.ccc.de dann immer noch noch ein Wiki, wo das alles aufgelistet ist. Das wird es wahrscheinlich auch dieses Jahr wieder geben. Schaut euch einfach mal um nach dem Stichwort Chaos Everywhere.
Ja genau und die die einfachste Möglichkeit ist auch einfach, also man muss jetzt auch nicht unbedingt irgendwo hingehen. Man kann auch einfach, wenn man möchte, zu Hause auf seiner Couch sitzen und sich da reinklicken. Weil dieses Streaming, was jetzt schon erwähnt wurde, was man auch gemeinsam gucken kann in den Hacker Spaces, kann man natürlich auch einfach zu Hause sich anmachen und dann statt Netflix einfach mal Talks gucken.
Oder statt die Weihnachtszeiten mit der Verwandtschaft verbringen. Wäre ich in der Stelle vorsichtig, würde ich auch sehr diplomatisch nur gegenüber der Verwandtschaft formulieren.
Kein Problem, da macht man auch für die Verwandtschaft eben den Stream auf dem Fernseher an.
Da kann man ja sozusagen die Vorträge gucken. Also da gibt es ja sehr viele, aber kann man sagen, worum geht es denn dieses Jahr?
Ich glaube, mit einem Wort kann man das definitiv nicht.
Aber gibt es sozusagen eine Art Schwerpunkt, weil man sagt, ok, dieses Jahr geht es schon in die Richtung Kopfhörer, die uns belauschen.
Also das Motto ist Works for me. Was heißt das?
Das hört sich aber für mich so an, wie wir waren zu faul, uns ein Motto auszudenken. Ganz im Gegenteil. Also die Idee hinter Works for me ist nicht, also es ist wieder ein Spiel mit einer Doppeldeutlichkeit natürlich. Auf der einen Seite läuft dieses Englische, aber auf der anderen Seite ist Works for me auch so ein bisschen so ein saloper Ausdruck, den einem ein Entwickler entgegenwirft, wenn man sagt, deine Software ist aber kaputt.
Ja, aber sie läuft doch auf meinem Rechner.
Genau, es läuft doch bei mir. Das heißt, so ein bisschen diese Idee, ich habe so meine Sphäre und in dieser Sphäre funktioniert alles. Das kann kulturell sein, das kann, wie jetzt, wo es ursprünglich herkommt, rein technisch sein. So dieses, in meiner Welt ist alles heile. Wenn du ein Problem mit meiner Software, mit meiner Welt hast, dann ist es bei dir kaputt. Das ist ja nicht meine Schuld.
Natürlich meinen wir das jetzt nicht ernst, sondern das ist natürlich sarkastisch, ironisch. Was ist jetzt wieder die richtige Form?
Eine Überlegungsanregung.
Genau, davon wollen wir weg. Also genau von dieser Haltung, die einfach viele haben, die sagen, das ist doch nicht mein Problem, warum soll ich mich damit beschäftigen? Wir haben das ja schon gehört damals bei Vorratsdatenspeicherung, ich habe nichts zu verstecken, das ist nicht mein Problem irgendwie. Dann irgendwie Mening sitzt im Knast. Ja, ich sitze ja nicht im Knast, das ist ja nicht mein Problem. Also man hat immer wieder ganz viele Leute in der Allgemeinheit, die sagen, ja betrifft mich nicht, mein Leben ist gut.
Genau, das hatten wir auch schon als Motto. Also das steht in der Tradition von not my department oder gated communities, gerade im letzten Jahr.
Und hier ist es noch ein bisschen weiter, so es geht mich nicht an, sondern für mich ist das okay. Und das geht auch so ein bisschen fähig, wo viele sagen, sich sozusagen aufregen hier, die Situation ist für Flüchtlinge schlecht, für Frauen in irgendwelchen Bereichen oder dies oder jenes und sagen, na ja, also für mich funktioniert das aber so, wie es ist total gut. Warum sollen wir was ändern? Fänd ich doof. Statt eben da ein bisschen größer. Und darauf soll halt aufmerksam gemacht werden, dass man einfach mal überdenkt. Ja, schön, dass das für dich funktioniert. Aber wie sieht es denn für den Rest der Welt aus? Sollte man das nicht ändern, damit es für alle gut funktioniert?
Jetzt, wo das gerade sozusagen darum geht, es geht um alle. Es wird ja gerade diskutiert oder es scheint eine Diskussion zu geben. Also Erdgeist, jemand, der auch schon häufig im Chaosradio war, hat einen Artikel geschrieben, darüber, dass es anscheinend sozusagen bei manchen Leuten so eine Meinung gibt, wie naja, irgendwie, was wollen diese ganzen Fremden auf dem Kongress? Das sind doch alles gar keine echten Hacker. Ist das sozusagen, ist es eine Diskussion, die wirklich stattfindet? Oder sind das verirrte Einzeltäter?
Oder wie ist da die Stimmung?
Diese Stimmen kommen immer mal wieder auf. In meinem Umkreis muss ich jetzt sagen, eher vereinzelt. Aber natürlich gerade eben im Zusammenhang mit Ticket sind ausverkauft oder sind sehr schnell weg und stehen jetzt kurz davor, ausverkauft zu sein, ist dann immer die Sache, ich habe kein Ticket bekommen, aber da kommen Leute, die sind gar keine Hacker, aber ich bin da oder hier, der und der Hacker und der hat gar kein Ticket bekommen und Schweinerei war sollen denn die ganzen da. Und meine Meinung ist, dass das nicht wirklich der Wahrheit entspricht. Also, weil ich mein, dieses Jahr wurde ja beim Ticketverkauf auch die Möglichkeit gegeben, dass Leute, die zum Beispiel Engel waren, also Helfer im letzten Jahr, sogenannte Tokens bekommen haben, ebenso auch Speaker oder andere Leute, die eben Teil wesentlicher Teams waren, damit der Kongress auch funktioniert, damit die dabei sind, damit eben der Kongress auch im nächsten Jahr funktioniert. Und es gab auch die Möglichkeit, über Hacker-Spaces vorher Tickets zu beziehen. Das heißt, man musste eigentlich nur irgendwo jemand kennen, Kontakt haben, fragen und hat dann so einen Token bekommen, um sich vorher ein Ticket zu kaufen.
Also im Endeffekt, wenn man Hacker ist, weiß man, wie man ein Ticket bekommt.
Genau, aber dann kann man eigentlich sagen, wenn man irgendwie Kontakt zu den Leuten hat, dann sollte man jemanden kennen. Darüber kriegt man ein Ticket und damit kommt man auf den Kongress. Das wurde in diesem Jahr sozusagen schon adressiert, weil wir einfach das Problem hatten, dass Leute wirklich kein Ticket abbekommen haben, die aber wesentlich für die Funktion des Kongresses sind, die einfach sich ums Netzwerk kümmern, ums Video oder so. Wir sagen, okay, wir brauchen die da.
Ja, aber sagen wir, ist das wirklich eingesogt, weil die... Also ich habe ja, also ich erlebe den Kongress auch schon seit ein paar Jahren und ich finde es für mich, weil ich jetzt natürlich auch selber nicht so der Elite Hacker bin, eine totale Bereicherung, dass da ein großer Ort entsteht, wo so ganz viele Leute zusammenkommen und sagen so, hey, ihr seid alle willkommen, wichtig ist nur, dass ihr euch interessiert und dann könnt ihr mal gucken. Das empfinde ich ja als totale Bereicherung.
Aber das scheint dann nicht überall so zu sein, oder?
Also muss man jetzt Angst haben, dass... Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich erlebe das hauptsächlich, oder ich habe es jetzt hauptsächlich so richtig krass erst über Twitter erlebt und erlebe das hauptsächlich als, ich sag mal so, als Shitstorm im Nachgang dieser Ticket-Debatte, dass ich, ich habe kein Ticket bekommen und deswegen seid ihr alle doof. So ein bisschen ist vielleicht ein bisschen vereinfacht, da mag noch ein bisschen mehr hinterstehen, aber das deckt sich halt nicht mit dem, was ich so im realen Leben erlebe. Da gibt es andere Debatten.
Das ist aber eine Umstellung. Also wir machen seit, ich bin jetzt seit über zehn Jahren beim Kongress und das hat sich verändert, also wie halt die Gesellschaft dort hat sich verändert. Früher waren es wirklich ganz einzig und einzig nur Hacker und jetzt sind es mittlerweile halt auch Hacker und Familien und das müssen halt auch. Genau und das ja und Transgender und okay. Ja genau. Wir müssen auch miteinander lernen, dass sich das dieses Umfeld halt verändert, dass da auch mehr Leute reinkommen, die vielleicht noch nicht so viel Ahnung haben, so wie ich vor 13, 14 Jahren. Das verstehen manche nicht.
Und es ist ja einfach so Technik und diese ganzen Themen, womit sich der Chaos Computer Club beschäftigt, rücken halt immer mehr in den Alltag. Es kommt immer näher dran. Die Leute interessieren sich da mehr und natürlich sind dann auch solche Veranstaltungen zu den Themen immer interessanter. Sie kommen auch immer mehr in die Medien, die Leute hören davon, die wollen hinkommen. Und ich denke, das ist etwas, viele sagen halt, wir wollen wieder zurück zum alten Kongress, wo wir eben wirklich dieses Jahresversammlung sozusagen des Chaos Computer Clubs hatten, wo es wirklich nur um uns ging, wo wir zusammen hockten. Und das ist der Kongress nicht mehr. Da hat sich einfach weiterentwickelt. Es ist so ein bisschen das Aushängeschild geworden. Es ist für mich eigentlich eine unserer Öffentlichkeitsveranstaltungen geworden, wo wir einfach zeigen, wer der CCC ist und was es ist. Und die Leute einfach teilnehmen können und auch einen Einstieg finden können in diese Welt. Aber es ist ja nicht so, als wäre das die einzige Veranstaltung im Chaosumfeld. Es gibt noch ganz, ganz viele Veranstaltungen. Es gibt einfach neue Veranstaltungen, die diesen familiären Charakter haben, wo halt vor allem die Hacker, die Nerds aus der Szene eben hinkommen und sich treffen. Und das ist für mich einfach so ein Generationswechsel. So ein bisschen. Also auch von diesen Veranstaltungen. Die entwickeln sich weiter und man muss da immer ein bisschen schauen, was wird da raus. Und das ist halt gerade als Softwareentwickler, was doch viele von uns sind, ist das was, was wir eigentlich kennen. Und in der Softwareentwicklung gibt es auch so was, das nennt sich Retrospektiven. Das heißt, man soll regelmäßig betrachten und zurückschauen, wie haben sich eigentlich Dinge verändert und kann ich alles noch genauso beihalten, wie es ist oder muss ich Dinge ändern in meinem Prozess, in meinem von meinen Sachen? Und das ist was, was hier einfach auch einfach mal nötig ist, zu reflektieren und zu überlegen, was ist der Kongress eigentlich geworden und wo wollen wir damit hin? Und ja, das ist halt in den letzten Jahren war das erst mal größer werden und Wachstum.
Okay, und jetzt würde ich doch noch mal gerne wissen, was passiert da inhaltlich bei den ganzen Vorträgen. Also ich meine, es gibt ja sozusagen, es gibt noch nicht das Programm, also wann welcher Vortrag stattfindet, aber man kann schon sehen, welche Vorträge es geben wird. Ihr habt doch bestimmt schon einmal reingeguckt. Ich will jetzt von jedem von euch ein wissen, wer jetzt okay, das ist ein Vortrag, interessiert mich, den finde ich vielleicht gut. Also ich habe spontan einen Vortrag im Kopf noch, da ging es darum, wir haben uns, da muss ich jetzt gerade mal ein bisschen rumladen, ich probiere es zu beschränken. Jetzt wo dieser ganz große IP-Bereich in IPv6 aufgemacht wurde, der ja wirklich riesengroß ist, also man vergleicht das immer gerne mit, alle Sandkörner auf der Welt können irgendwie eine Adresse haben und da haben sie alle gesagt, wunderbar, wenn es so viele Adressen gibt, dann kann es ja garantiert niemand Bösen geben, der alle Adressen durchscannen kann und irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken finden kann, das ist viel zu viel. Und natürlich kommt da wieder irgendein Typ von der TU Berlin und sagt, ja, hier, da, hab da. Also da will jemand das ganze neue Internet scannen, das ist viel größer als früher. Er will quasi die Körner in der Nüge erzählen. Nein, nein, er will nicht erzählen. Er hat. Okay, Carina.
Ja, also mein Favorit ist eigentlich ein ganzer Track, den es neu gibt, nämlich den Space Track, also ein Thema, das ist irgendwie ein ziemlicher Hype. Seit den letzten Jahren schon in dieser Nerdszene irgendwie ist es dieses ganze Thema Raumfahrt. Und da kommt der aktuelle Vorsitzende der ESA, der European Space Agency und ja, oder Director ist eigentlich das richtige Wort und hält einen Vortrag über den Mond und das European Space Exploration Programm. Also einfach das, nachdem wir jetzt uns ja eigentlich von dem Mond so ein bisschen abgewandt haben, das aber aktuell ist, was wir uns wieder mehr angucken. Und ja, das ist halt der Herr Wörner, der war auch vorher der Vorstandsvorsitzende des DLR, also des Deutschen Forschungszentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt. Und ja, da bin ich einfach sehr gespannt, weil das ist einfach mal was ganz Neues auf dem Kongress und gerade auch diese über diese Mischung von Wissenschaft und Raumfahrtbetrieb und Hacken, das finde ich passt einfach extrem gut zusammen.
Aber du arbeitest ja auch da, oder?
Ich arbeite beim DLR, daher ist das sozusagen mein früherer hoher Chef und dadurch ist das natürlich anwesenheitspflicht für mich.
Macht ihr, dann sorgt ihr auch dafür, dass der nächste Marsland dann nicht wieder wegen deiner Softwarefehlers abstürzt?
Wir geben uns alle Mühe.
Sehr gut. Matthias?
Ja, Space und Wissenschaft bringt mich auch im Prinzip direkt zu meinem wahrscheinlich favorisierten Talk. Das wird in diesem Jahr, so wie wahrscheinlich auch letztes Jahr, wieder methodisch inkorrekt werden. Der sozusagen die Show gewordene Version des großartigen Podcasts von Nikolas Wurl und Reinhard Remfordt und die werden wahrscheinlich wieder eine großartige Show auf die Bühne bringen und es wird mit Sicherheit wieder Feuer.
Also wir können dort abreißen. Das ist die letzte Sache, die im MCCH stattfindet, der Kongress. Ich habe gehört, wir müssen Besen rein übergeben. Das heißt, es ist aber nicht darüber gesagt, wie viel davon in Containern hinterlandet.
Richtig, also ich bin auf jeden Fall gespannt, was die Jungs da auf die Bühne stellen werden. Es wird auf jeden Fall sehr unterhaltsam werden.
Gut, Sokrates?
Ja, ich bin da sehr zerrissen. Das Problem ist, ich will eigentlich ganz viele, aber das, was mich am meisten interessieren wird, wird die Infrastructure Review sein. Heißt? Die gesamte Infrastruktur, also das Netzwerk, das WLAN, wie viele Clients und so weiter, wo die ganz tiefen Nerds aus dem NOC, aus dem POC, aus der Seidenstraße berichten, was sie denn so alles geschaufelt haben an Daten von A nach B, von C nach D und wie die ausgesehen haben, aber nicht was drin war.
Also, das heißt, muss man wirklich sagen, zum Chaos Communication Congress wird ein Netzwerk im CCH aufgebaut und das ist dann irgendwie der größte Datenknoten in Europa, oder was? Ja, wir hatten vor Jahr und Tag, als wir noch in Berlin waren, mehr Anbindung des Kongresszentrums, als es zur damaligen Zeit in ganz Afrika zu ganz Afrika gab. Das war schon... Wird das WLAN funktionieren? Wenn jetzt jemand sozusagen dahin geht zum ersten Mal und sein Computer mitbringen will und Angst hat, oh nein, da sind ja viele böse Hacker, die machen bestimmt mein Computer kaputt. Sollen wir den mitbringen oder sollen wir lieber zu Hause lassen?
Also den eigentlichen, den man immer benutzt, auf gar keinen Fall. Und wenn dann auf jeden Fall, hat man ein Backup.
Oder eine frische Installation und nach dem Kongress einfach wieder alles platt machen, neu installieren und kreativ lege tut eh gut, sicher sein.
Keine wichtigen Daten darauf haben.
Man sollte halt gucken, dass man alles auf ein aktuelles System hat, also vorher alle Updates einspielen. Man sollte gucken, dass man nur verschlüsselt surft, weil alles, was unverschlüsselt ist, wird halt einfach mitgelesen. Das ist immer eine gute Empfehlung, unabhängig von Kongress oder nicht. Mein Empfehlung ist eh, es gibt so viel Programm und so viel zu tun, sich da jetzt hinter seinem Laptop zu verkriechen, das ist gar nicht so schlau. Vielleicht ist es cleverer, ein Tablet oder so etwas mitzunehmen, wo man eben mal den Fahrplan nachgucken kann, also das Programm und ein paar andere Informationen. Das kann man eigentlich sehr schön, einfach ein frisches Android drauf, nur die Service und Passwörter angeben oder Dienste anmelden, die man wirklich, wirklich braucht. Nichts, wo irgendwie die Kreditkarte vielleicht noch hinterhängt. Und Passwörter danach einfach einmal neu setzen. Das ist eh immer eine gute Sache. Und dann kann man das eigentlich anfangen, dass die Hand das einmal alle neu setzen. Und dann ist man eigentlich auch ganz, ganz gut.
Genau, wenn man sich das mal zurechtgelegt hat, dann kann man das direkt zur Routine werden lassen.
Genau, und es ist auch gar nicht so schlecht, einfach mal drei Tage im Jahr mal nicht E-Mails zu checken.
Na, ob ihr das schafft, ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich werde jetzt auch zum Kongress fahren und werde euch beobachten und gucken, ob ihr ja auch alle eure Geräte nicht gerade in der Hand haltet und drauf guckt. So, wir haben jetzt heute viel geschafft hier im Chaosradio Nummer 229. Ich wollte trotzdem noch fragen, ganz zum Schluss, haben wir noch ein Thema vergessen, wo wir gesagt, das haben wir nicht mehr geschafft, aber sollten wir heute vielleicht wenigstens mal hinterherklicken?
Also ein Thema nicht, aber eine kleine Ankündigung haben wir noch. Und zwar findet am 13.12. der im CCCB, also dem Chaos Computer Club Berlin, der nächste Datengarten statt. Das ist ein Dienstag.
Und für diesen Datengarten haben wir uns etwas ganz Besonderes ausgedacht, und zwar Lightning Talks. Und zwar könnt ihr da innerhalb von ungefähr einen zehnminütigen Vortrag einreichen und ihn bei uns einfach mal auf unserer Bühne präsentieren.
Und wir streamen das Ganze. Wir haben genügend Live Publikum. Themenbeschränkungen? Ja, nein, kommt mit allem, was ihr wollt. Hauptsache zehn Minuten.
Also es wäre gut, wenn ihr das Thema bei uns vorher einreicht.
Genau, also prinzipiell sind wir relativ frei. Ob wir jetzt irgendwie, weiß nicht, was über eure Flohfarben hören wollen oder so, weiß ich nicht. Aber prinzipiell machen wir halt, wenn wir viele haben, fällig eine Auswahl. Das müssen wir mal schauen. Aber eigentlich ist der Plan First Come, First Serve. Und es geht wirklich darum, eine Idee vorzustellen, ein Problem, das Lieblingstool, was irgendwas macht oder irgendwas. Das ist eben das Schöne an Lightning Talks. Hat nämlich zwei Vorteile. Man ist halt total frei. Aber für die Zuhörerinnen, wenn es halt blöd ist, ist es halt auch einfach in zehn Minuten maximal vorbei.
Okay, also entweder selber Vortrag halten im Cosco Butter Club Berlin oder vielen kleinen vorträgen Zuhören. Vielen Dank.
Und wir reden übrigens nicht über Chemtrade.
Genau. Und für mehr Informationen findet ihr da auch auf unserer Webseite www.https.berlin.ccc.de mehr Informationen. Und da findet ihr auch Möglichkeiten, dann eben euren Lightning Talk anzumelden.
Sehr gut. So wird es gemacht. Diese Sendung kann man da bestimmt auch irgendwann finden. Ich bedanke mich jetzt von Anne, nee, bei, Herr Gott, ist gleich vorbei. Sokrates, Matthias, Carina und Danimo. Vielen Dank. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Ich spreche Mikrofone und empfehle mich, normalerweise mit dem Spruch, verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups und lasst sie nicht überwachen. Aber dieses Mal gibt es noch etwas Besonderes. Und zwar normalerweise spielen wir hier einen ganz bestimmten Endtrack. Da hat sich jemand beschwert, da immer diese komische Rapper. Und außerdem gibt es das Design vom Chaos Communication Congress und eine offene Lizenz. Nicht Creative Commons, sondern do what you want, also mach mit dem Design was du willst und denk über die Frauen.